me
だけは
蚊によって財政破綻
そうビジョンによるとこのまま地方か祖母がそう
2050年には向け重化が進み
経済しては
居住している地域の
おおよそには慰安婦下 x 化すると推測
数字から計算すると
200年の秋田県は居住たによって財政破綻するのではと私は推測しています
また厚生労働省が発表した平成28年の
人工灯台統計では1弦は7項目ではそう取ったことからも
業重化が促進されるのではと推測しています
際国はそうなったのは
出生
脂肪率
出生数から死亡数を引いた自然増減率
婚姻ビズ
死因別死亡率の元
の欠陥失態
自殺率
県人口は4月1日で87年ぶりに100万人の大台を割っており
少子高齢だと人口減少に歯止めが利かない状態が浮き彫りになっています
人口減少の問題電話若者の減少
高齢者の増加にあります
若者人口が減少高齢者の人口が増加
これの何がイケナイんばー
4つの問題点を挙げて
1少子化な進展は経済成長率が年々低下していきます
消費者の減少や市場の縮小が生じ
産業界全体へさまざまな影響を及ぼします
ファン
若者1人が抱える高齢者の数が増えると健康の社会世論
破綻につながり食べませんよっ伝統的な京者イベントの消滅など地域活性の低下に
つながります
しかしこれらのよの問題点は私ひとりの一般人を解決すること
いきません
だから誰かが入ってくれるだろうそんな風に思ってきました
しかし誰から何とかしてくれるそんな時期はとっくに過ぎているのかもしれません
の地域にもこのような問題に直面してみませんか
あるいはひとりで解決できない問題を迎えてみませんか
その問題に対してあなたは何か行動をしていますか
私は大学の進学をきっかけに秋田を訪れることになりました
北海道でを知ることができなかった新たな価値観や文化
旅熱田犬が好きになり
そのまま10年ほど移住集 sunday
そしてそこ
秋田のおいしい食品の魅力がパッケージではの映さやきれていないのでは
また
秋田県の観光パンフレットなども
いつも同じだ
乗ってい
力を伝えている
伝えられるのでは
と感じることが多くなりました
卒業後は3年ほどデザイン会社に勤めその後独立しホームページデザイン事務所を is
デザインファームを立ち上げました
デザインと聞くとん mac で美しく外見を整える仕事思われがちですがデザインは
直訳で設計を意味しています
私はデザインゴール企業あるいは個人の問題をビジュアル面で解決する者というふうに
認識をして仕事をしてきました
そしてデザインの仕事を通じ
秋田の企業や個人と関わっていくことで秋田県の問題が自分事とした得るようになり
ました
また25歳を過ぎたあたりに自分で何ができることはないかと考えるようになりました
そこで独自で抱えて行なってきたミッションを解決するチャレンジをご紹介します
mission 1可能とたちを見える化せよ
私が個人事業主の女性ということもあってか
同じ個人事業主 after トップの女性からお仕事を依頼されることが多くあり
ました
めちゃさよなだからなぜ起業しようと思ったのか
それぞれのストーリーを知って育児に彼女たちの前向きな姿勢や太いをより多くの人に
知ってもらうことで授業がもっと知ってもらえるのではないかと考えるようになりまし
た
彼女たちの想いスキル一人一人の
生い立ちなど
取材ライティングを行い記事の掲載をできる
彩りという web サイトを立ち上げることにしました
皇帝つだけではなく
思いや思想に勝ちを付け
ブランディングしたいと考えたんです
また掲載する人物を女性起業家とすることでターゲット層を明確化し
web サイトの目的を分かりやすく
ユーザーに伝えることも注視しました結果
ウェブサイトを見た方からお問い合わせがあり
彩りから企業のマッチングがかなりました
ミッションにビジネスの楽しさをデザイン性
これは私が独立して感じていたことなんですけれど
起業してからは強豪が吹くないと思う
モチベーションを上げるのが困難だと感じていました
より生産性を上げるためには楽しく仕事をするということが重要ですそこで企業が利用
できる
花や他の部隊みたいなものがあれば
以下ここに立ちたいという目標につながり
モチベーションが上がるのではないかと考えました大げさに言うとビジネスのパリコレ
みたいなのを作りたいと考えたんです
そこで演出や見せ方をしたコピーなど見栄えにこだわった
ビジネスイベントを開催しました sns の連動もあって
低コストマーケティングでしたが当日は100名以上の参加者が集ってくれ
ビジネスマッチングに成功しました秋田のビジネスイベントで
デザインやエイターデイズ妻が入ったものがなかったのでクリエイティブなイベントを
作ることに成功しました
mission 3階かを稼げターゲット渋谷
いろいろチャレンジしていくうちに明日県内で右傾化というものを感じるようになり
ました秋田をより良くしていくためには秋田県がいたら
はより多くの人を巻き込んでいくことは必須だったからですそこで私がターゲットにし
たのは東京都渋谷でした
木育乳は渋谷ハチ公の故郷は秋田県のオーダーでだったということです
渋谷と秋田が身近な関係になることで新しい仕事やクリエイティブな情報はぜに入ると
考え
わたしは渋谷にもデザイン事務所オフィスデザインファーム
at shibuya を作り秋田と渋谷の二拠点生活を始めました
私が考える渋谷の魅力は
常に新しいことを見続けていまちということです
新しいリー
新しいビジネス
新しいカルちゃん
新しい価値観すべてがクリエイティブな町
それが渋谷です
そして秋田の魅力は変わらない想い
でーとー歴史街並みでこれは面白い発見でした
ザッツの街は日本一正反対な魅力を持っているんですこの
毛髪が大きければ大きいほどお互いにメリットになる美人が生まれるのではない
でしょうか
ここで問題なのがシビラの人はアルタのことをよく知らないということです
そこで私があったと守備をつなぐ役割をしていきたいとおもいます
これはやってきたことなんですけど
例えば渋谷のラジオパーソナリティになり
秋田の企業等4グラム企業ゲストに呼んでフリートークでそれぞれの良さを伝え合う
番組を作成したり
渋谷の商業施設
秋田と渋谷に冠レースがアニメーションを作成したり
秋田と渋谷という女え
企画デザインし渋谷に関する人と秋田に関連する人でワークショップを行ったりしまし
た
そして今後取り組んでいきたいのは秋田の兼野手と一緒に
秋田の特産品など渋谷デー pr できるようなイベントや web it で開く
ただ経済に向けて走っ
できるようなプラットフォームの作成
秋田を立てとわぁ継承の企画デザインなど秋田と守備を詰まる
取り組みを行っていきたいです最後にこの動画を見てくださっている皆様
特に学生の方へみなさんこれからいろいろなことにチャレンジし失敗したり成功したり
して社会でたくさんのこと
を学んでいくのかと思います私がこの動画で最後に伝えたいのは何かを変えたいと思っ
たら問題をポジティブに解決するアイディアと行動力がすべて
ということです動画を見て自分の住んでいる地域で何かできることはないか
地方の問題点はどこにあるんだろうなど
少しでも考えてくれた嬉しいです
200年後の未来は私たちをつくっていきましょう
以上株式会社デザインファーム代表取締役遠藤高いでした
では